mon père était un grand homme un héros alors ils
disent que parfois le monde n'a pas besoin d'
un autre héros parfois ce dont il a besoin c'est d'
un monstre
tu as manqué à mon prince
quelque chose te trouble
le sultan se prépare au combat il
faut 1000 garçons pour son armée
y compris ton fils  sous ta mère
détourne le regard tu ne peux pas nous protéger je trouverai
un moyen j'ai attendu une éternité
[musique
] qu'un homme de ta force arrive
bienvenue chez toi
qu'est-ce que tu cherches je veux le
pouvoir de détruire mon  ennemis et sauve ma
famille
bois dracula bienvenue dans ta vie
ce qui t'arrive
et la chose que l'homme n'a pas peur d'un fantôme
quelque chose d'autre
je vois le diable en lui
penses-tu que tu es vivant parce que tu
peux combattre la
vie à cause de ce que j'ai fait pour te sauver
alors n'oublie jamais qui je suis
[Musique]